so again if you want to challenge me you
can challenge me
um i said i was going to play bike jazz
who i guess i overlooked earlier
challenging me from position i'm scared
oh was this uh was this a mate in like
16
no this is double rook odds okay
i feel like bike just said so white jazz
is provisional here
but said their rating is i think around
1100
okay no brooks i mean it's actually okay
because rooks don't really
come alive until the end game so i just
have to try and win
before we reach an end game
but it's kind of sad because i can't
castle like either way
and then there's increments so i can't
dirty flag my opponents
at least i'm not blindfolded ah
are you serious big alex redeemed go
blind
where's my blindfold actually do i have
a blindfold
wait a minute it might be behind the
green screen
give me one sec
ah here it is
okay i found the blindfold
that was incredible timing because i i
said
at least i'm not blind and then i saw
the thing
okay blind time how do i even do this
it's been so long
where's my headphone thing
okay let me just play a move quickly so
i don't flag
okay oh thanks for the bits
yeah i'm about to say goodbye to the the
visual world oh i have to change my
settings too
ah
references is it game behavior
input moves with oh say good game upon
defeated
defeat or draw oh i guess yes i'll be
polite
uh oh that's my face
but what does sg stand for oh sunglasses
okay uh
speech speech synthesis ready
okay let's do this three
okay so wait i have to remember oh mike
just has a traditional london i just
have a hippo
okay that's easy
okay so rook odds plus blindfold let's
play e6
e6 so
bishop d3 i saw a clear
a clear fan of my my london opening
i'll play 97. knight d7 yeah i really
miss my
rooks
but that's okay i have my hippo
my rookless hippo don't mess with uh
the rookless hippo
and knight g7 is actually a nifty move
it looks like an innocent developing
move
but i'm threatening i might be
threatening something
or i might not be white four minutes
once
black four minutes three seconds oh upon
time
opponent completed like the
quintessential
london setup built the triangle and the
hat
it's basically an illuminati
wonder what it means
the nice thing about not having a rook
on 8 i can play queen 8
like instantaneously or
instantly wait short castle
short castle i'll play e5
e5 alexa what's the difference between
instantly and instantaneously
according to an alexa answers
contributor instantly means that once or
d takes e5
instantaneously means happening so soon
in relation to something else
that no delay is perceptible the
difference between these adverbs is
subtle
and there is plenty of gray area between
them gray area
separate wait what's in one plane d
takes e5 oh de5 d e5
d takes e5
wait what about gray area also i think
i'm winning a piece here
because e4 is coming
i'm also attacking the bishop this is
like the one kind of
tragedy for many london players is to
run into e5 and then e4
oh but i don't have a knight on f6
i'm not even threatening e5
ah thanks for subbing by the way hey
eric hey hey
how's it going hope you're doing well g3
who says that someone i know that name
actually
someone always says that d takes bishop
g3
maybe z nation bishop g3 bishop g3
um i think i'll play queen eight
[Music]
i can play f5 too f5 is
really ambitious let's do it
f5 yolo
[Music]
i'm just going for the all-out attack
and hopefully it works
guess it could be toggy he's capable of
saying hey
alexa turn on the fridge oh
alexa will actually remind me uh at
midnight
or later the fridge is off what's the
reminder for
oh you you already know i think rookie
one okay
you better know mind you tomorrow no
what
rookie one rook e1 i'm gonna forget to
turn that off too
rookie 1 allows me to fork and win
connect 4 simultaneously
uh e4 e4 let's go
i'm still down to ruxo sadly
i'm trying to win back material
the double fiance is kind of nice
i'm hoping really hoping for knight
takes
e4 and then i'll play f takes e4
and fork again that's unlikely though
bishop b5 yeah a good move
so i think what i should do
is avoid trades at all costs and play c6
c6 so i'm attacking the bishop
uh and the knights still attack too so i
should still be winning a piece
and avoiding any any trades
at least trades of minor pieces
yeah my minor pieces are very very
important to hold on to
especially my light squared bishop
bishop a4
a4 so now
now i probably should just take the f3
he takes f3
check the time one minute 18 seconds
[Music]
2 minutes 45 seconds okay plenty of time
queen takes f3
queen f3 um
so my pawn on c6 c6 is attacked i'll
play knight e7
knight e7 defending with the knights
i wanted to play c5 but my bishop on b7
is not defended
i might play some kind of b5
just get ready like get rid of this
bishop and then somehow prepare c5
bishop d6
oh fancy move it's a very fancy move
hmm
[Music]
that's actually a kind of annoying move
too
[Music]
[Music]
oh no yeah
but i mean even if you are missing
something you can still be alive
you just have to to be grateful for what
you have
so here i'm actually attacking a lot of
things
please take my knight actually take the
take the right knight
i guess both knights can be taken by the
bishop
or take the wrong knight bishop takes e5
ah
he took the right knight i was hoping
for bishop takes e7 then i take the
queen with check
okay so here i can take back should be
five takes e5
uh so unfortunately we traded some
miners but i have the bishop here
okay opponent saw the knight was
attacked
uh we guess i'll have to move the bishop
let's move it back to c7
bishop c7 rook ad1
yeah that's a natural move i'll play
queen b8 queen b8
so forming some battery knight d6 check
really 96 oh i don't think my opponent
saw the queen helps control
so let's take that bishop takes d6
rook takes d6 yeah queen g6 queen takes
d6 what's the damage
rook d1 wait am i only down the exchange
because i won i won a full rook and i
won a piece earlier
so i'm only down the exchange i guess
white has an extra pawn
roof d1 rook t1
uh i'm still worse i want so much
material but i'm still down
uh i'll play queen c7 i guess queen c7
because i wanna i wanna have my bishop
defended and eventually play
play the c5 move um
i guess i'll play king f8 first king f8
just unpinning the pawn oh g4
so spicy oh my pawn on f5 is pinned
where's my knight that's on e7 i think
i'll play c5 c5 unleashing the beast
maybe i should i should have played b5
first
now i don't have queen c6 queen e2
could play a6
okay queen e2 is non-threatening i'll
play a6
ay 6 white 0 minutes 12 seconds oh
very low on time black one minute 10
seconds okay
b4 so time is good relatively i'll play
b5 e5
attacking the bishop bishop b3
yeah c4 c explosive let's go
chasing the bishop further back now
queen c6 queen c6
a three now queen h1 queen h1 checkmate
okay black is victorious
oh my eyes it's so light
yeah this diagonal the xylose was so
nice
that's challenging i guess the time
situation helped
time situation uh my opponent was a bit
pressure
oh but who chose me
i feel chosen thanks for that big alex
oh big alex was the one who redeemed the
blindfold nice
i i tried to deliver
i should work for should work for
postmates
not sponsored yeah this is nice
i can provide some some tips uh
sound standard
i mean opening was super solid
i hallucinated here that
i had e4 when in reality i don't have e4
but then that e4 turned out to be
possible it's tricky here
um i mean probably best to move away the
bishop
like bishop b5 here or this
oh king gupta can get me sponsored
i'm open i'm open to possibilities
um
yeah i think the the biggest mistake was
96
because it gave away the night and then
then it led to a situation
where only down a little bit of material
um but yeah
so one tip with playing material odds is
like the hippo is probably the best
setup
because it just tries to avoid trades
and you keep the
you at least maintain the fee
encountered bishops
oh it's xy sparks ah
so i was so i said z nation who's
another
one of the few founders of the channel
the xy sparks solving for 30 months wow
thanks so much for subbing yet again
i made a new lectures account so you
wouldn't go over my name
and you still went over it lol that's
why i d-i-d-n-t have the 1100 rating i
said before but thanks for the game
eric gotcha yeah well it helps when your
leeches account
i guess matches your twitch account it
just makes me
makes it easier for me to to find uh the
challenge
a good game thanks again for the bits uh
that was a fun game if it goes on
youtube hello to youtube
um i haven't had blind content in a
while
on youtube and thanks everyone for
subscribing
hope you'll get a good quality sleep
that's actually
oh goodnight also good bishop